words programs online at book TV org
in our book TV we want to introduce you
to university of Wisconsin professor
Jordan elenberg professor elenberg what
do you do here I'm a professor about
madatha teach math big kids little kids
all kinds of people you also read books
how not to be wrong is the name of it
the power of mathematical thinking in
this book you write that mathematics is
not settled yeah that's where it would
mean well it or subtle there wouldn't
still be my petitions would I mean you
know math I thought math was certainty
math was formulaic math said this 1 plus
1 equals 2 at all times well that part
is settled 1 plus 1 equals 2 we can
agree on that but there's much more
that's not subtle you know math it's a
process you know it's many thousands of
years old I mean there's no there's
never been a culture or civilization
without math any more than there's been
one without music or without drawing
right it's one of the basic things that
we do but you know in many ways we are
still wrestling with the question that
we're confusing to the ancient Greeks
and the Sumerians and the Egyptians like
that's I mean we've expanded our circle
of knowledge to a large extent but
there's much more we don't know them
that we know what's an example of that
but what don't we know yet well just to
give an example that's been in the news
lately we have known for thousands of
years that there are infinitely many
prime numbers you know numbers like 2 &
5 and 7 and 13 that can't be factored
basically atoms if you like of numbers
but here's the crazy thing we don't know
we actually don't know remember I
mentioned 5 and 7 they're only two apart
they're almost right next to each other
we don't know whether there are
infinitely many pairs of primes that are
too apart we don't know whether these
little twin primes as they're called
whether they just go on and on forever
or whether they eventually stop people
have wondered for hundreds of years and
we steadily get closer and closer there
was a big advance in this area a couple
of years ago but we still don't know we
might find out tomorrow we might not
find out for another 50 years we might
never find out so what what what does it
matter if we know what prime numbers are
are not well did they serve a purpose
well that's a great question
here's what we know about math
um it seems to describe the basic
structure of the way things are the
universe and just reality now any
individual mathematical fact do I know
why we need to know that is that going
to cure cancer tomorrow is that going to
build a better missile probably not
and I wouldn't actually be allowed to
tell you if it were with the missile but
but history has shown us that somehow
advances in math always bring with them
massive advances in knowledge of all
kinds of things we are constantly using
things that were developed by
mathematicians purely for the sake of
understanding right purely because there
was a puzzle just about the way things
are not with any idea of practical
application and yet the practical
applications do tend to come in your
book comment first of all where'd you
come up with the title how not to be
wrong oh I had that title for a long
time before I even knew what the book
was going to be about actually with it's
probably to some extent the reference
there is I don't know if you ever saw
this was an old Monty Python sketch
called how not to be seen and it was
about um how to hide and if you didn't
hide it's sort of a bit because I sort
of tricking people under standing up and
then they would explode them with a bomb
very typical kind of 60s British humour
so I think I think it's in some sense
comes from that but I mean the real
reason for that title is because I want
to I want people to think about
mathematics not in this kind of sterile
series of exercises which to be quite
honest for many people that is their
interaction with math right that's their
interaction with math in school but it's
not every mathematical technique we have
every mathematical object every
definition every theorem was created to
solve a problem that's its origin was
created because people were confused
about something and they wanted to be
less confused and one of the things I
try to do in the book is to take these
mathematical things and and talk about
what problems they were originally for
like to go back in history to when do
people not understand this why do they
want to understand it and what was it
like the process of figuring it out what
is the Pythagorean theorem solve
well the Pythagorean theorem actually
was pretty practical right from the
start I mean the Pythagorean theorem
tells you
if you have a right triangle so if you
have a triangle or one of the angles is
a nice square angle like this and you
know how long this side is and you know
how long this side is you want to know
how long the other side it so if you are
actually physically building a structure
and you know when you build a building
like right angles are pretty useful it's
pretty cool for your building foot not
to be slanted but actually to stand up
straight you know you want to brace
across beam across the bag and all the
rectangle you actually do need to know
like how much wood you're going to need
so so that one it's actually I mean
that's much less obtrusive theoretical
than most of the stuff I work on in my
day job you tell the story in your book
professor about Abraham Wald who is she
who was it yeah this is kind of an
amazing story so wall was the guy and he
was actually I mean the pure the pure
kind of mathematicians let me tell you
but he grows up in Hungary and then was
working in Austria and then in
authorities when the Nazis take over
he's got to leave right he's got like a
lot of people used to get out quickly he
ends up in the United States working in
an economics Institute and during World
War two he is working at this top-secret
math and physics lab right near Columbia
University I actually had no idea until
I was researching this is there it was
such a thing was kind of like the
Manhattan Project except it was actually
in Manhattan it was all these very
famous statisticians including Wald and
the story that I tell in the book is a
group of generals come to this group the
statistical research group was called
the srg it comes to srg and they come to
Wald and they say well we noticed
something funny the planes that are
coming back from flying missions over
Germany there's more bullet holes in
some parts of them than others they're
getting hit more in fuselage and they're
going to hit less in the engines and
they said we want to know how much more
armor should we be putting on the places
where the planes are getting hit more
like how much more heavily to do the
armoring the fuselage me this would be a
question right because you want to put
too much armor on or the plane won't fly
right you'd want to put too little out
of the planes not safe so they said
Abraham Wald maybe is there some kind of
mathematical formula you can give us
right for like how many times more armor
we should be putting on the
parts of the plane that are getting hit
more and Walt says you guys have it
completely wrong you have to put the
armor where there are no bullet holes
okay this is like kind of weird right
you put yourself in the position of the
general why are you telling me to do the
exact opposite what make sense what wall
points out to them is that it's not that
the Germans can't hit their planes on
the engine it's that the planes that get
hit on the engines are the ones that are
not coming back from Germany so there's
simple the ones that there's the planes
that they're seeing that's not like a
random sample from all the planes right
they are seeing the ones that didn't get
shot in the engines and so didn't get
shot down so what's interesting about
this is that he didn't actually give
them the kind of answer they were
expecting like he didn't give him a
formula he didn't give them a
spreadsheet
he didn't give them a number nonetheless
what he did was deeply mathematical
mathematics is not just about numbers
right I mean mathematics is about
understanding and it's about taking a
question and asking what assumptions
underlie that question is it correct is
it even the right question in the first
place I mean giving the answers to
questions is like pretty easy but asking
the right question that is profound and
that's what mathematical thinking is
really about in your book you also talk
about the Laffer curve is the Laffer
curve first of all what is it and is it
mathematically defensible yes and I
defend it actually I mean it's
interesting so the story probably not a
two story true story but it's too good
not to tell anyway is that it's called
Lavra curve because was drawn on the
napkin by Arthur Laffer who was a
well-known conservative economist and
thinker during the Reagan administration
and what the curve is meant to depict is
the following here so here's a question
how high should taxes be what should the
tax rate be well there's two extremes if
your tax rate is a zero if you don't
talk people at all then the government
is not going to get any tax money that's
pretty clear what's also true though
it's let's say the tax rate was a
hundred percent every single penny you
are in gets taken in taxes um then
nobody's going to work right or if they
work they're going to sort of find ways
to hide it from the government and the
government also gets no revenue so
zero percent tax rate no government
revenue 100 per Tyson tax rate no
government revenue somewhere in between
rate has to go up and then down that's
the mathematical fact that a curve that
is down here at the end point has to
have a maximum somewhere in between
there's some optimal rate what Laffer
believed now you have to imagine the
virtual blackboard here well laugh it
believed that we were over on this side
of the curve were increasing taxes would
actually bring government revenue down
instead of up now laughing was probably
wrong about that that's what economists
at the time mostly thought and I think
that's what economists in 2015
pretty universally think so he was wrong
about where we were on the Laffer curve
but he was right about the general
picture that there is some rate of
Taxation which is so high that
increasing it further paradoxically
reduces the amount of taxes that the
government actually get so he's often I
mean he is often kind of scoffed at it I
think to some degree unfairly Steven
Pinker comes up in your book how not to
be wrong well Pinker is a very
interesting guy right because he's a
psychologist I mean he comes from the
social scientist but I think he's very
mathematically inflected and I was
really struck by his most recent book
which is very quantitative in nature and
he writes about the fact that in many
ways for all the terrible things that we
see in the news and in the newspaper
every day I could have to like turn the
front page over when I come to my house
play hide it from my kids because I
don't want to ask if that's a lot of
questions for all this he argues that
the world is actually much safer and
more pleasant and quieter and more
peaceful now than it ever has been in
human history and one part of his
argument is to say that while we have
these kinds of horrible events on a
global scale things like World War two
which killed tens of millions of people
the world is that is also much bigger
now so that in terms of the percentage
of the world's people who are killed or
otherwise injured by some calamity there
were things that happened a long time
ago they were proportionally speaking
quite a bit worse so I think this raises
a very interesting question which is do
you think that
a calamity that kills 10,000 people in a
world of population let's say 100
million is the same thing as a calamity
that kills let's say a hundred thousand
people in a world with a population ten
times as big a billion it's the same
percentage of the world's population
right but is one worse or better than
the other but are they're the same this
is kind of an interesting question
because it mixes both math and just your
general Moral Sentiments right it's not
a question that you can actually answer
by math alone like there's no math
formula for like which thing is worse
than which other thing on the other hand
you also can't answer the question
without at least in part thinking
quantitatively of like what are you
doing if you try to measure the scale of
some kind of disaster whether it be a
natural disaster or a war can I think
Steven Pinker appears in your chapter
how much is that worth in dead americans
yes I in sort of a tingly title chapter
I guess but that chapter about I mean
that chapter is it refers to this very
common practice when something bad
happens and what to us is a foreign
place people try to convey the sense of
it they say well this you know this
island is a population of 20,000 and
climate change threatens to displace a
thousand of them who live in the
low-lying region that's one of 20 people
so they said they would say oh that's
the same as if 15 million Americans were
displaced so as you know how much is
that in dead americans or how much has
been displaced Americans people always
try to sort of let's play natural right
I mean for an American audience to sort
of take something that happened far away
and be like Oh what what is the
equivalent thing an American certainly
sure killed in the terrorist attack ten
Palestinians are killed right and you
would say well that's the same as like
five hundred Americans or something like
that so what I say here so when I say in
the book I mean I think this is a great
example of you can set up the math to
give you that answer I mean that's a
perfectly good mathematical answer to a
certain question the question is is that
the right question because I think at
least to me you get into quite morally
dicey territory when you say oh 10
Israeli lives
mean the same as 500 American lives I
mean you can sort of do that on your
spreadsheet but when you actually listen
to the words that are coming out of your
mouth you're like wait is that really
what I want to say and I think that's a
great example of the mathematical
thinking have to go hand in hand with
all the other parts of your cognition
like your moral mind your a static mind
your general commonsensical mind but we
use that statistic quite a bit don't we
I mean can you kick it no there's not
the point of your book but can how much
lying is done with statistics in your
view I think that is one of the points
in my book by the way and actually I
think what's interesting is that when
you talk about lying you think about
intentional malfeasance right you think
about somebody's really trying to
snooker you and pull the wool over your
eyes I actually think most of the bad
statistics in this world and let me tell
you if you're at the breakfast table
with me like you will hear like me
snored about something like probably
every day everything in the paper that I
just roll my eyes at I would say most of
the time the large majority of the time
that's not somebody intentionally being
honest that's somebody who has fooled
themselves there's something that they
want to say there's something they want
to believe and they find a way to to
enlist some kind of numerical data to
their cause and it's not because they're
intentionally trying to cheat you it's
because they're in Fitness that's
cheating themselves
professor elenberg we talked today a
political issue is income inequality
right how do you look at that as a
mathematician I mean I think a really
interesting question is even how do you
measure income inequality like how do
you look at two different societies and
say is this one more unequal than that
one or how do you look at the same
Society in different periods of time and
say how has inequality changed I mean
here at least at least to the best of my
knowledge if you compare the United
States of today with the United States
that I grew up in let's say in the 1880s
I don't think there's any dispute that
our society is more economically unequal
now I think basically you could use any
measure you want and that story is is
pretty clear
if somebody sits down at the blackjack
table should they play for two hours or
10 hours mathematically ah boy I have to
say I think I have been through a
blackjack table once in my life I lost
20 bucks and I think it took me about
four seconds so in that ring I don't
think I have enough capital to sit for
either two hours or is that are you
talking just asking questions you talk
about gambling in your book I do what I
think gambling is such a fascinating
test case because once again people have
moral feelings about it
they have mathematical feelings about it
I think everybody knows that for most
people in most circumstances stances
gambling is not a wise investment right
I mean if you have money that you want
to do something with probably playing
blackjack with it is not the most
revenue enhancing choice that you could
make this leads actually to like I mean
what I write about in the book
especially is a veritable one of the
most popular kind of gambling there is
which is playing the lottery not quite
as glamorous as going to Las Vegas and
playing the blackjack table but it's
incredibly popular and it's distributed
throughout the country almost everyone
will tell you it's a bad bet so why do
so many people do it so I write a lot I
mean there's a crazy story that I write
about about a lottery in Massachusetts
with a cork that actually allowed
several groups of people to rather
reliably make quite a lot of money over
many years but that's of course a very
unusual situation right most people who
play the lottery are going to lose on
average most of the time the conclusion
of but I think the conclusion the most
people would say is but people actually
enjoy playing the lottery I mean partly
yes they play because they hope to win
but in some sense I think there's an
argument that you get a certain amount
of money's worth of entertainment out of
each ticket you buy and that's certainly
a big part of people's motivation doing
um I think it depends who you ask
I think there's it's obviously very
dangerous territory to talk about can
you quantify enjoyment can you quantify
how much fun you're having and say how
many dollars is that worth so on the one
hand you can see that that's a hard
problem on the other hand people do
trade dollars for fun all the time right
people sort of say I'll go to this movie
oh it cost $12 I don't want to go oh it
cost $5 I'll go so whether or not it can
be made mathematically precise people
are certainly making these kinds of
judgments all the time so I would say
certainly it lots of economists would
say that's absolutely a mathematical
question you have different kinds of
what are called utility the utility of
entertainment the utility of happiness
the utility of a safety right some
people ask people dislike gambling
because they don't like that
suspenseful feeling of being unsafe or
feeling like your arrest right so for
those people that would be like a
negative utility of playing the lottery
so I think it's quite standard in
economics actually list sine numerical
values to all these things professor
Jordan elenberg the Baltimore
stockbroker where'd you come up with
that and who is he
the Baltimore stockbroker yaza it's a
figure of mathematical folklore and it's
kind of a con game I'll explain how it
works like here's how here's what
happens you get you get in the mail a
newsletter from a sock tipper I've got a
great tip for you this particular stock
is going to go up next week buy it now
so we know the story the least as old as
we would like get newsletters in the
mail I don't know exactly how old it is
so you read this and you assume it's a
scam but you know just for kicks you
look at the newspaper the next day and
you see that indeed that stock did go up
no it's not interesting well you forget
about it
but the next week you get another
newsletter in the mail and it has
another tip it says so-and-so stock is
going to go down if you've got it sell
it like the stock is a stinker and you
read the business section the next day
and you see that just as the stock just
as the Baltimore stockbroker predicted
the stock has gone down another week
goes by you get another tip another week
goes by you're getting the tip
ten weeks in a row this guy correctly
predicts the motion of whatever stopped
he's written about in his newsletter and
at that point right you're pretty amazed
at that point you're ready to like give
this guy your life savings this guy
somehow I don't know how he's doing it
but he knows what's going on okay that's
the Baltimore stockbroker what don't you
know about this story what you don't
know is that on the first day when you
get that newsletter the Baltimore
stockbroker actually sent out a thousand
newsletters 500 of them said the stock
was going to go up 500 of them said the
stock was going to go down okay what
happens to the 500 people who got the
bad dip they never hear for the
Baltimore stockbroker gasps and the next
week 250 people get it a tip that so
it's a stock is going to go down the
correct one 250 people get the tip at
that same stock it's going to go up so
that guy is covering all his bases right
10 weeks later it's probably down to
just you you're the lucky one or
depending on how you look at it the
unlucky one who who is completely
convinced and all he needs is one right
that's the way cons work all you need is
one sucker on the line do you know you
don't have to have a thousand one is
enough and so I mean it's a what is sort
of parable symbolizes mathematically is
that you can't always make a good
inference from the information that's in
front of you sometimes you need to know
like not only what you observed but also
when you didn't observe right you did
not observe like all the chances this
guy had you're like it's amazing how
could somebody get ten stock tips but
it's correct in a row well if you've got
a thousand chances you can do that a lot
of crazy stuff can happen if you give
yourself enough chances to get it right
it's finally professor big data and
mathematics I mean it's the word of the
day right the word of the year the word
of the decade um I love it I mean it's
an amazing subject and it's I would say
I mean I think about this kind of stuff
a lot of my research life um it's not so
much that it's big if I had one thing to
say about it we could do another hour
but it's not so much that it's big you
know if I want to add up a trillion
number mathematically that's no more
difficult to profound or interesting
than adding up to numbers same operation
just a larger
yeah what's interesting is the data that
we have now we have it from social
networks we have it from internet usage
NSA has it from God knows where I mean
we've got a lot of stuff it's not just
that it's big it's that it's structured
right it's it has all kinds of
structures embedded in it the structures
of network networks of people Geographic
structures time structures
mathematicians are I would go so far as
to say having to invent a new kind of
Statistics as we go the old methods are
just not suitable for this kind of data
they were designed for other things like
controlled trials that we did like one
at a time now we kind of got the fire
hose trained on this and we're trying to
figure out how to do it so it's actually
incredibly exciting time when there's so
many new problems just trying to figure
out you know how do you make sense of a
spreadsheet that's like a trillion by a
trillion right the human brain cannot do
that that's not what it's built to do we
have to figure out how to interpret
those numbers and and we don't know yet
it's not it's not magic right so I think
a lot of people will have an interest in
making it sound like we really
understand how to deal with that data
how to make good inferences from it I
don't think we do yet I hope we will
we've been talking here at the
University of Wisconsin with mathematics
professor Jordan elenberg how not to be
wrong as the name of the book the power
of mathematical thinking there's a book
TV on location in Madison